évidemment on comprendra jamais le
problème arménien si l'on ne se réfère
pas à l'effroyable génocide de 1915
cette année là par centaines des
milliers les arméniens sur la mine et
c'était donc pendant la première guerre
mondiale
les arméniens turcs venait de refuser de
combattre la russie d'où la décision
terrifiante du gouvernement de l'empiré
ottoman de l'époque d'exterminer la
minorité arménienne
il y eu au moins un million de morts les
instances internationales société des
nations ni nations unies n'ont jamais
reconnu officiellement le génocide
arménien c'est la raison qu'invoque les
terroristes obtenir la reconnaissance
internationale d'un faits datant de 1915
c'est la raison qui l'invoquent pour
perpétrer leurs attentats qui se sont
multipliés en france depuis 1975 avec
l'assassinât de l'ambassadeur de turquie
et surtout depuis 1979 8 juillet 79
attentats contre les bureaux des lignes
aériennes turques 22 décembre 79
l'attaché de presse de l'ambassade de
turquie est assassiné novembre 79 nouvel
attentat contre les lignes aériennes
turques 5 août 1980 attaques contre le
consulat de turquie à lyon 10 novembre
80 attaques contre le consulat de
turquie à strasbourg et enfin 4 mars
1981 deux diplomates turcs sont
assassinés à paris